cette forêt sauvage qu'on aurait comme
oubliés abandonnés laissés seuls se
façonner par le temps qui passe est
désormais forêt de légendes contes de
fées ou de rêveurs une forêt musée
devenu simple conservatoire d'espèces
une réserve dont le seul rôle est
d'assurer la pérennité des patrimoine
écologique
aujourd'hui la forêt vivante celle qui
nous est familière pour les baladeurs
sous bois véritable espace de liberté de
découverte et de nature est une forêt
cultivée un domaine géré bien sûr pour
la production de cette richesse
renouvelable qu'est le bois mais aussi
entretenu afin de protéger la diversité
biologique de la forêt et de sauvegarder
notre environnement des agressions
extérieures
la forêt une fabuleuse aventure aux
senteurs de tradition et de savoir faire
les appelants aussi les technologies les
plus modernes
il y à 300 millions d'années bien avant
l'arrivée de l'homme sur la terre la
forêt est formé de fougères géantes et
dames important écailles mais bientôt le
froid succède au chaud et la végétation
tropicale cède la place à la glace
entraînant ainsi la disparition de trés
nombreuses espèces végétales et animales
la forêt valeur au fil des années
s'adapter aux variations climatiques
changeant en permanence de taille et de
composition elle va ce mode est peu à
peu en se diversifiant donnant ainsi
naissance aux espèces que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
l'homme va à son tour modifié la
physionomie de la forêt en puisant dans
ses ressources pour se loger se nourrir
et se chauffer
si au temps des gaulois et recouvre la
totalité du territoire en l'an mil au
début du moyen âge avec le développement
des exploitations agricoles des
communautés religieuses les surfaces
boisées vont alors commencé à diminuer
régulièrement
jusqu'au 19ème siècle la forêt aura
comme seul allié les rois qui seront
aussi de véritable bâtisseur les
entretiendront alors les forêts pour y
pratiquer la chasse à courre ou y
récolter leurs boîtes marine
la révolution va faire tomber des têtes
mais aussi beaucoup d'arbres désormais
sans défenseur la forêt atteint alors
son plus bas niveau
1827 c'est la création du code forestier
et avec lui la volonté depuis plus de
150 ans de reboiser et pour la première
fois de gérer la forêt pour mieux la
protéger une mission confiée depuis 1966
à l'eau nf l'office national des forêts
pour les forêts publiques
la forêt ou plutôt les forêts un
écosystème complexe un milieu naturel
dans lequel coexistent en étroite
symbiose végétaux et animaux recouvre
aujourd'hui un peu plus du quart de la
planète
si les forêts boréales est tempérée
principalement celles de l'hémisphère
nord comme la forêt française continue à
augmenter et ce contrairement à ce qu'on
croit généralement les forêts tropicales
elle régresse de façon dramatique de
l'ordre de 15 millions d'hectares par an
l'équivalent de la surface de la forêt
française
la forêt une véritable usine écologique
à l'échelle de la planète qu'il faut
aujourd'hui absolument sauvegarder pour
que puissent vivre les générations
futures
à
on l'a dit une belle forêt c'est une
forêt cultivée c'est le rôle de la
sylviculture
l'idéal pour le forestier étant
d'obtenir un arbre au fus au droit ellis
un arbre sans branches donnant ainsi un
bois sans ne un bois de valeur
or ce n'est qu'à l'âge adulte au bout de
plusieurs dizaines d'années voire plus
de 200 ans même pour les chaînes qu'on
saura si le choix de la semence faites
par les générations antérieures était
judicieux ou non d'où toute l'importance
pour le forestier de la sélection de la
graine
pour récolter les graines de qualité il
faut aller les chercher là où elle se
trouve tout en haut d'arbres
soigneusement sélectionnés et à une
période précise celle de la
fructification
c'est le rôle de ces cueilleurs des
cimes qui doivent récupérer les cônes
renfermant les graines avant que ceux-ci
ne s'ouvre dix personnes au vent la
précieuse semence
la graine compte dans la mémoire d'une
espèce d'arbre on est ainsi certain de
transmettre l'ensemble du patrimoine
génétique aux générations futures une
semences sélectionnées qui servira à
reboiser les terrains en friche ou à
régénérer des forêts
ce qui est vrai pour les pins est vrai
également pour les êtres et leurs fruits
les fèves ou pour les chaînes et leur
gland bien que pour ces feuillus on ne
fasse que ramasser les graines tombé à
terre
les semences ainsi récoltées sont
ensuite séchés et conserver en chambre
froide dans ce centre unique en europe
la sécherie aux élèves de la joue dans
le jura français
des semences forestières sélectionnés et
amélioré permettant de constituer les
forêts de demain à partir des meilleurs
arbres et des meilleurs peuplement
existants une autre technique on le
verra tout à l'heure consistera à
manipuler les jeunes d'espèces
sélectionnés afin de créer des arbres
possédant des qualités nouvelles
les plans une fois obtenue commence
alors pour le forestier un long travail
de fourmi qui va lui permettre
d'accompagner les nouveaux venus pendant
la première partie de leur vie puis
viennent les opérations de nettoiement
consistant à supprimer intrus et tiges
en surnombre afin de donner aux plus
beaux sujets des meilleures conditions
de croissance
et
ainsi année après année se créeront se
reconstitueront de nouvelles forêts et
avec elle de nouveaux paysages un
magnifique livre d'image que nous vous
proposons maintenant de feuilleter
ensemble
épicé entre
la forêt française qu'ils recouvrent le
quart du territoire ces 14 millions
d'hectares à gérer dont 70% par plus de
3 millions d'euros prier terres de
forêts privées les autres 30 % soit 4
millions 400 mille hectares sont
constitués de forêts communales ou
domaniale géré par le nfc
gérer la forêt c'est pour les forestiers
la cultiver et l'aménager afin qu'elle
puisse apporter aux hommes ce qu'ils
attendent d'elle la sauvegarde d'un
patrimoine ancestral l'aménagement des
espaces consacrés aux loisirs sans
oublier l'aspect production avec 50
millions de mètres cubes créés chaque
année par les forêts françaises et dont
70% sont constitués de bois d'oeuvre
d'industrie et 30% environ de bois de
chauffage
et c'est dire qu'en matière de gestion
forestière écologie économie ne sont pas
antinomiques bien au contraire et tout
l'art va consister à harmoniser et à
équilibrer les différents massifs
forestiers entre eux ainsi dans les
régions très urbanisées et très peuplée
on privilégiera le rôle social et
écologique de la forêt alors que pendant
le même temps dans les région très
boisée et souvent peu peuplée c'est
l'aspect économique et production de
bois qui sera mis en avant par le
forestier
ainsi aujourd'hui les bénéfices
provenant de la vente de bois des forêts
productive permet de financer les lieux
de loisirs et de récréation comme les
forêts de l'île de france ou celle en
déséquilibre écologique et économique
comme beaucoup de forêts
méditerranéennes
gérer la forêt c'est bien sûr aussi en
assurer sa desserte pour l'accès du
public la lutte contre les incendies ou
l'organisation de la récolte du bois
pour la ménagère mieux' mans et
rationnellement la contrainte du
forestier va être là encore le temps car
rappelons le il faut de 25 à 250 ans
pour qu'un arbre arrive à maturité
aussi toute la difficulté va être de
suivre la forêt de façon permanente
pratiquement au quotidien comme ici les
branchages automatique à l'aide d'une
drôle de machine appelée malicieusement
le sage et cela en gardant toujours
présent à l'esprit l'objectif à long
terme d'aménagement préalablement
définis et pouvant atteindre 200 à 300
ans
reste la technique employée par le
forestier pour parvenir à ses fins
futaie jardinée futaie régulière tani-
sous futaie mais une chose est sûre pour
qu'une forêt vive il faut impérativement
soit en permanence soit à période
régulière que des arbres jeunes remplace
des arbres vieux car qu'on le veuille ou
non une forêt qui vieillit c'est une
forêt qui meurt
avant de décider de tel ou tel
aménagement pour une forêt donné comme
ici celle de fontainebleau en banlieue
parisienne on va en dresser un véritable
inventaire qu'on va reporter sur des
cartes pour en faciliter
l'interprétation
sur cette vue prise par le satellite
spot chaque carreaux de couleur
correspond sur le terrain à un carré de
20 mètres de côté les feuillus sont en
rouge les résineux en vert foncé et
envers clair les seuls recouvert d'herbe
cette opération c'est ce qu'on appelle
la phase d' analyse au cours de laquelle
on va déterminer ce que l'on peut faire
avec cette forêt compte tenu de ses
caractéristiques
cette imagerie par satellite traités par
ordinateur est un des nouveaux outils de
la haute technologie à la disposition du
forestier une sorte d' aide à la
décision complémentaire de l'observation
sur le terrain
trente centimètres de poudre
sur le pea feu
la phase l'analyse terminée le forestier
va devoir synthétiser ses objectifs et
déterminer ce qu'il veut faire de telle
ou telle parcelle c'est le choix
primordial de l'essence à cultiver et
pour cela là encore il va bénéficier des
acquis récent de la haute technologie
nous sommes dans le centre de recherche
de la fosse elle anne hengy près de
paris la sélection génétique pratiqué
ici sur des arbres comme l'épicéa le pin
maritime où le douglas pour les résineux
le peuplier ou l'eucalyptus pour les
feuillus rencontre différents critères
rectitude dutronc vitesse de croissance
qualité du bois résistance aux attaques
des insectes et des champignons ou
adaptation à des milieux particuliers
ici par exemple on va effectuer un
prélèvement de méristème sur des micro
boutures d'arbres d'élite quelques
centaines de microns soit 30 à 40
cellules de tissu végétal ces tissus
siège de division rapide et nombreuses
vont permettre de régénérer des milliers
d'arbres de haute qualité pour le
reboisement
on
ces organismes vivants emprisonnés dans
des bises inerte pont être déshydraté et
congelés dans l'azoté liquide à moins
196 degrés et constituent ainsi des
conservatoires de ressources génétiques
permettant ainsi de sauvegarder des
espèces menacées
après réchauffement quelques années ou
quelques décennies plus tard ces
organismes vivants pourront être
réveillé régénérer et multipliez par
exemple parents brio génèse somatique
ce procédé consiste à faire des copies
génétiquement conforme à partir
d'embryons ou de semis et demain grâce
aux progrès de la recherche à partir
d'arbres âgées
par manipulation génétique c'est-à-dire
par l'introduction de nouveaux gènes on
va pouvoir aussi conférer aux arbres des
propriétés remarquables comme la
résistance à certaines maladies liées à
la sécheresse et lutter ainsi demain
contre la désertification
la nuit il y à des arbres le vent
s'arrête sans bruit se déshabille et au
matin les gens de laval est dit avec un
sourire cette nuit le vent s'est calmé
par le vide sensini
quand je suis parmi vous arbres de ces
grands bois dans tout ce qui m'entourait
me cache à la fois dans votre solitude
où je rentre en moi même je sens
quelqu'un de grand qui m'écoutent et qui
même victor hugo
jadis les arbres étaient des gens comme
nous mais plus solide plus heureux plus
amoureux peut-être plus sage c'est tout
jacques prévert
domaniale de souche dans mon article 25
1230 18,235 1974 1230 12 8 270 milles
203 8 236 1234 1260 2260
1258 256 bits 254 8 252 8 250
mille deux cent cinquante mille
l'article 25 étaient dues aux
établissements parisot article 26 forêt
domaniale de souche dans 170 villes
soit 150
la vente de lots aux enchères
descendantes reste aujourd'hui encore
pratique courante pour les agents de
l'onef le premier vendeur de bois en
france avec 40% des bois commercialisés
pour une valeur annuelle de 3 milliards
de francs on
aujourd'hui 70 % de la récolte est
constitué de bois d'oeuvre pour le
bâtiment et l'ameublement et de bois
d'industrie pour les panneaux et le
papier
si l'on pardonne généralement aux
scieries qui laisse le bois dans un état
proche de celui de la nature les parties
en revanche ont la plupart du temps
considérés comme des assassins de la
forêt le papier détruit la forêt redon
journellement
une idée archi fausse qu'il faut
impérativement bannir car aucun arbre de
valeur en france ne finit sa vie en pâte
à papier celle-ci se nourrit en fait
essentiellement pour les 2/3 de coupes
d'éclaircie ou d'arbres malingre et pour
le tiers restant des déchets des
scieries
autre contrevérité à chasser malgré la
pâte à papier l'aspect de certaines
régénération de parcelles où d'aucuns
croient des opérations immobilières
sauvage et d'aiguiser la superficie des
espaces boisés aura en france était
multiplié par deux en deux sens entre
il est vrai que jusqu'à un passé récent
les agresseurs humain de la forêt n'ont
pas manqué lotisseur foncier
constructeurs routiers ou ferroviaires
exploitants de minerai et bien d'autres
le public ne disposons que depuis
quelques années des espaces spécialement
aménagés pour la détente la promenade et
la découverte de la nature
l'aménagement voire la création de
forêts nouvelle aux portes des villes
correspond désormais à un véritable
besoin pour des populations qui ne
disposent parfois guère de plus d'un
mètre carré perdure par habitant est à
côté d'une consommation passive de la
forêt on voit se développer une soif
d'apprendre la forêt peut-être pour
mieux l'aimer
à côté des 89 espèces d'arbres existant
dans les forêts françaises il ya bien
sûr la flore très diverses mais aussi la
faune les animaux de la forêt qu'on
appelle sauvage on en dénombre plus de
6000 espèces
les serres les biches les chevreuils ou
les sangliers pour les grands mammifères
sont de plus en plus nombreux et pour la
sauvegarde voire la pérennité même des
forêts la mise en place de véritables
plans de chasse est devenu nécessaire
la régénération c'est à dire le
renouvellement de la forêt ne peut en
effet se faire que si un certain
équilibre faune forêt existe or
aujourd'hui sert comme chevreuil non
plus de prédateurs naturels
pour l'ours le lynx ou ici le grand
tétras par exemple il s'agit là d'
espèce protégée car en voie de
disparition et toute chasse en est bien
sûr interdite
gérer la faune cela signifie ainsi
protéger les espèces rares ou en déclin
et à la verse limiter les espèces en
surnombre qui endommagent les forêts
en fait on ne devrait pas parler de
forêt mais plutôt d'écosystèmes
forestiers l ensemble extrêmement
complexe constitué d'éléments
complètement interdépendants
tout
un monde extraordinaire en forme de
décor fait d'un sol d'un climat et de
saison un décor dans lequel se mêlent et
cohabitent une multiplicité d'organismes
vivants grand et minuscules animaux et
végétaux avec eux aussi leur rythme
autant de scénarios variant à l'infini
une flore elle aussi très diverse fait
parfois d'espèces rares ou en voie de
disparition qu'il faut alors tout comme
les animaux protégés dans des réserves
biologiques véritable arche de noé à
l'abri des prédateurs et du temps qui
passe
avec la guyane ce département français
d'outre-mer situés en amérique du sud
sur l'équateur c'est l'exemple de
l'autre grand type de forêt la forêt
tropicale humide dont elle est
recouverte à 98% la guyane c'est en fait
un fragment de l'immense forêt
amazonienne primaire qui au brésil tout
proche notamment a subi des dégâts très
importants et certainement pour
longtemps encore irréversible avec un
taux de déforestation estimé à près de
trente mille kilomètres carrés soit pas
loin de 1 % de sa surface par an
heureusement en guyane on n'en est pas
là forêt faune et flore y conserve
aujourd'hui encore toute leur splendeur
comme leur caractère sauvage et naturel
un véritable réservoir génétique qu'il
faut impérativement sauvegarder
les rares places des forêts composées
d'indiens de bonis les des bois
vives de chasse de pêche et de
cueillette sans grand dommage pour la
forêt
aujourd'hui la forêt guyanaise se veut
l'exemple en matière de gestion d'une
forêt tropicale humide en transposant
ici les méthodes d'aménagement des
forêts tempérées dans le nord du pays en
bordure littorale aménagement et récolte
dirigé de bois tout en maintenant la
biodiversité dans le sud protection
étude du milieu avec la création de
réserves biologiques domaniale de
réserve naturelle et d'un parc national
qualifiée jusqu'à un passé récent
denfert vers une forêt inextricable et
inhospitalière puis de trésor vers une
forêt inépuisable de biomasse la guyane
ne compte aujourd'hui que très peu
d'entreprises forestières
car la grande diversité des espèces et
la dispersion d essence dans les
peuplements rendre toute exploitation de
la forêt guyanaise très difficile
cette déforestation massive en amazonie
tout proche comme en indonésie au zaïre
ou au congo commence à inquiéter la
communauté scientifique internationale
qui depuis quelques années multiplie les
conférences à l'échelle planétaire sans
pour l'instant de véritable progrès
tangibles
disparition de peuples indigènes
extinction de très nombreuses espèces
animales et modifications très sensible
des données climatiques due notamment à
l'effet de serre on le voit il faut agir
d'urgence s'il en est encore temps
comme tout organisme vivant la forêt en
permanence exposés aux maladies et à
toute une série d'agresseurs naturelles
ou d'origine lui même comme ici les feux
de forêt un véritable fléau à l'échelle
de l'europe méridionale qui voit ainsi
chaque année plus de 500 mille hectares
de maquis de garrigue ou de forêts dont
près de 10% en france partir en fumée
feux de forêt et bien sûr synonyme de
paysage sinistré mais il ya plus grave
encore la répétition des incendies au
même endroit entraîne une dégradation et
une érosion pratiquement irréversible du
sol et des formations végétales qui lui
sont associés les remèdes comme le
débroussaillage la plantation d'essences
peu combustible ou l'aménagement des
terrains boisés on les connaît mais il
coûte cher face à des bois de faible
valeur marchande reste que malgré ces
agressions les forêts européennes et
donc française continue à croître outre
fausses idées reçues elles n'ont jamais
été aussi belle et ce malgré les
sempiternelles alerte aux effets de
serre et autres plus acide qui
menacerait nos forêts autres agresseurs
les grands accidents climatiques comme
ici le vent le jet la sécheresse ou la
neige des éléments incontrôlables qui
endommagent cependant plus gravement les
sujets faible vieux ou malades enfin les
champignons pathogènes ou les insectes
ravageurs comme les scolytes qui vivent
sous les corses aux dépens de la partie
vivante de l'arbre agressent de aussi
plus gravement en les attaquant en masse
les arbres malades ou affaiblis par la
sécheresse signant le plus souvent leur
arrêt de mort
face aux agressions de la nature est ici
dans le massif des alpes à l'érosion des
terrains de montagne les forestiers ont
en charge de tout mettre en oeuvre avant
que ces phénomènes naturels ne devienne
risque à caractère catastrophique
menaçant hommes et équipements c'est une
des missions méconnu des agents de l'eau
nf qui doit trouver ainsi des parades
aux risques de débordement torrentielles
de glissement du terrain de chutes de
pierres ou d'avalanche
les remèdes à cette érosion des sols
sont bien sûr du domaine du génie civil
mais aussi du génie écologique avec
l'installation ou le rétablissement du
couvert végétal le plus souvent
forestier par reboisement engazonnement
ou en broussaille mans
dernier exemple de combat réussi contre
les éléments la mer le vent ici les
dunes des landes au sud de la france le
plus grand ouvrage maritime artificiel
d'europe réalisées au siècle dernier est
chargé de protéger le million d'hectares
de la forêt landaise des dunes
atteignant à certains endroits 130
mètres de haut qui sans entretien contre
l'érosion de la mer et du vent aurait
déjà avancé de près de 5 km
la technique employée consiste à
implanter les palissades brise vent dans
les parties les plus basses de la dune
et à poser des branchages et des
végétaux morts pour bloquer le sable en
place autre technique la mise en place
du tri des plastiques soient parallèles
à l'océan soit posée sous forme de
casiers afin d'obtenir un profil de
dunes correct
la restauration des torrents de montagne
comme celle des lunes des landes sont
deux exemples très significatif de ce
que parvient à faire l'intelligence de
l'homme pour dompter les éléments
naturels et redonner vie conservez
intact un site naturel un paysage ou une
forêt
ainsi les forestiers protégèrent et
enrichissent le patrimoine reçu du passé
aujourd'hui il tente de percer les
secrets des écosystèmes et les mystères
intime de ces êtres vivants afin de
faire de ces forêts des lieux de
richesses et de vie mais aussi de
transmettre dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
ce formidable trésor aux générations du
troisième millénaire les forêts précède
les peuples les déserts les suivent
écrivait châteaubriant il s'agit bien
d'un verset cette prédiction